A judge has permanently blocked Donald Trump
from using military funding to build his stupid
border wall.
This is being reported by slate.
A federal judge in Texas ruled against Donald
Trump wanting, trying to take three point
$6 billion from military construction funds
to build the border wall.
A permanent injunction has been made to block
Donald Trump trying to do this or doing it
on the basis that the executive branch, which
is where Donald Trump exists, does not have
the constitutional authority to take money
that has been appropriated by Congress.
The judge in this particular case was district
court judge David Briony's, a Clinton appointee,
which of course is going to be the subject
of Donald Trump.
And Trump is saying, look at these terrible
bias people has made a permanent what was
previously a temporary injunction from October.
This according to the Washington post, is
quote, the first instance of a local jurisdiction
successfully suing to block construction of
Donald Trump's border barrier.
Now there's a few things that I want to talk
about here.
Number one, uh, what we're really talking
about here is a form of theft and I think
it's important to use those terms.
Trump diverting military funds that have been
appropriated for the military and using them
for a pet political project that is a form
of theft.
Now is it criminal theft, the type that the
police come and arrest you for?
And then you know, you, you get yourself a
lawyer and try to get probation over.
No, it's not that type of theft, but it is
a type of theft.
And we know that this is the way Donald Trump
has operated in his business career for a
very, very long time.
Now, if you want to take the position of we
want to support and defend the military, we
need to treat those who choose to serve so
that we don't need a draft.
Well, you know, all the stuff that the right
claims to want to do, support the troops,
yellow ribbons and all of this stuff.
Military spending that has been debated and
uh, approved and appropriated.
It should actually be used to protect our
troops, to protect national security interests.
If you believe in American dominance around
the world, that's not my politics, but again,
I'm thinking of it from the point of view
of a right winger.
You would want it used for that to project
power.
You know, all this stuff that right-wingers
claim to want and whatever.
You should be furious that the president is
saying, I'm going to take the money 3.6 billion
and I'm going to build a border wall.
Particularly when we've seen time and again,
that the entire idea of a border wall to fix
the problem of undocumented immigration is
simply a bad idea from the get go.
We have looked at that in detail when we talk
about a number one of when, if you really
want to deal with the problem of undocumented
immigration, then you've got to deal with
number one, uh, overstayed visas.
Number two, let's deal with the, the proximate
causes in other countries that are pushing
people to want to come to the United States.
That would be a far more stimulative use of
money.
It wouldn't require stealing 3.6 billion from
the military in order to build the wall.
And then of course, you get to the specifics
of the wall.
You can get $100 a tool at a hardware store
as we discussed and cut the prototype wall
that Donald Trump thinks is virtually impenetrable.
You can, um, uh, climb over it as we've seen
done in a number of viral YouTube videos.
And then in the end, remember undocumented
and documented immigrants commit crimes in
the United States at lower rates than native
born Americans.
Even undocumented immigrants are stimulative
to the economy.
Not only because there are entire industries
that depend on them, including agricultural
industry and the restaurant industry, but
by virtue of being here undocumented, very
often undocumented immigrants, as I've said
before, this isn't used, are paying into welfare
programs that they will never draw money from.
I'm not cheering about that.
I think people who pay in should be able to
draw benefits, but that's the reality that's
stimulative, that that keeps, uh, that floats
the viability of a lot of these programs.
And, um, on, on every level, the quote and
analysis of this issue that we've seen from
the right is completely wrong.
Um, we are also at some point, hopefully going
to see Trump held accountable by Trump is
for the fact that he didn't build the wall.
If the Trumpists realize this, because you
have two different situations with Trumpists
on the wall.
One is they believe he's building it.
Trump has tweeted dozens of times the wall
was being built.
It's not, there are some sections of wall
that were already there before fencing that
were scheduled to be replaced and they are
being replaced, repaired or whatever you would
call it.
So there, there are some trumpets who say,
Oh, he is building it now we saw CNN interviewed
six white women without college education,
um, about how Trump is doing for people who
voted for Trump in 2016 and when at least
one of them was presented with the fact that
Trump hasn't built the wall.
That's a promise he hasn't kept, she excused
it by saying, well, that's not because of
Trump.
That's because of Democrats or something else.
Right.
So that that's motivated reasoning to find
someone else to blame for Trump's failures.
And I would expect both of those to play a
big role in Trump retaining a lot of his 2016
support in 2020.
Let me know what you think about all of this,
about the judge's decision, about the wall,
about Trump voters thinking he either is building
it or that it's not getting built, but it's
not really his fault.